you ever talk to police officers and
when they make arrests in certain parts
of this country and the one thing they
say is they go dude
some people are so dumb you would you
would [ __ ] fall over like in the
majority like you'll see you did this
crime how do you think we're gonna get
away with it well they're so [ __ ]
dunno that's what I always said when
feel like old you hope your kids a
professional athlete you know he's an
actor can mean with like I still won't
be dumb because you can't dumb you can't
teach like there's some people are just
mad their IQs are super low and you have
conversations like a homicide detectives
talking about how she was driving this
guy to the station and he said what do
you live and she said near the airport
and he goes oh yeah so what he did you
fly to work then she was like what he's
like you fly to work she's like no I
Drive because okay then why do you live
near the airport well because I just do
now to locate I have to take you and put
you in jail for the rest your life
obviously and that's exactly where you
belong
so thank you so much for playing but not
this time around a time later playing
life jigna lost
thanks bread for us Aerosmith need dumb
[ __ ] so you fly to work it's a lot of
work
no I don't lie linear Airport after like
you cease bro
is this a [ __ ] yo you textured shine
she did and he goes he goes what right
well obviously I thought I told you that
was a long time ago that this kid from
Louisiana hell of a football player yeah
my first time at CU with scenarios yo
y'all white boy
how you spell chair I like this yeah I
can you imagine chaired believe that
[ __ ] yes I just felt chairman could
get serious yeah just bill chair never
educated [ __ ] crying you public high
school college yeah you want to step it
out even [ __ ] spell it right well got
his degree behind me of course
there you go that's football [ __ ] you
really we're doing this all programs Oh
- oh my god you off [ __ ]
you've ruined my day how the [ __ ] did
you make it here so much my college how
are you not dead in there oh my god I
will I'll see on the other side I have
you done a movie that wasn't really
successful I've done movies that didn't
make a lot of money uh I don't really
have a movie where I think oh god that's
so bad I feel like the worst of them
would still be the best movie you'd ever
watch on a plane I think all but well I
wonder with a guy like you like you at
now you're not even 50 yet and you've
done is you know you've been as
successful as it gets right let's be
honest so now what are what do you ever
find yourself kind of being like I don't
know what else to do or that's partially
why I like doing stand-up yeah because
you know if you say okay the bar is can
I be as good in a special as Maria
Bamford or Hannibal or Louie or Mulaney
the bar is so high yeah that it's it's
so fun to try to see if you can get
there and to me that's always what I've
been interested in movies and television
just you know can I do my best work and
I get the most out of me something
original right so that's why it's so fun
to go to the will Bergen bus and I'll be
at the Wilbur it's on the Rhode Island
and Providence and Ridgefield
Connecticut you you've been around
company forever since your kid and
people say so sure boy Brogan will say
this is the Golden Age of comedy right
now yeah it's better than it's ever been
you agree with that I think so he's
really I mean I wasn't expecting on that
I mean you could look at it like no one
is as good as Richard Pryor so it's not
no one's as good as Steve Martin so it's
not but I think that we always look
through it look at it through the prism
of that time and when you're young what
had an impression on you but if you're a
young kid and you don't know anything
about comedy and you see oh hello with
Kroll and Mulaney on Netflix
that's your Steve Martin yeah or Maria
Bamford what she's doing I'm credible I
mean yeah
she makes me laugh I mean there I want I
favorite she in many ways like for me
having been in this business as long
Maria Bamford is so good at shocking
like for me I think she's if you want to
talk about original I think she might be
the most original
Tomic male/female yeah I ever me and
gets better and better he says right now
I'm still looking at GSP he might need
to give that up I had a conversation
with Dana white last week on the phone
he made me an offer not for a fight I
will not reveal on here what it was but
made me an offer for something I'm
assuming it's an analyst job they're
trying to build in London or something
like that what else what else would gain
I have no idea I said what about Cece
said GSP does not want to fight I said
well that's not what I hear I said I'm
I'm hearing he wants to fight me his
coach told me that he wants fight he
said if I could make the juice roof
happen I make em but he doesn't have a
fight you I'm telling you so I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on out there
um so I'm represented and I'm the same
agents as GSP I will tell you this he
does want to fight I told you guys from
the very very beginning it's medicals
Dana knows this the UFC noses the
commission of this biz bings team noses
GSPC Massey knows this so we knew it was
going to be delay he's just trying to
get what the thing the floater in his I
think if so he's healthy enough to fight
and he's bringing it putting his best
foot forward so this old GSP doesn't
want to fight he's scared to fight
that's all [ __ ] that's all fakeness
stay well